many on the Left are not happy with
President Trump's plan to put a 60-day
pause on legal immigration critics
claiming the president's just playing
politics and that the move is dangerous
but Trump says he's doing it to help the
economy Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi suggesting the move is about
diverting attention he's a poor leader
he ignores his own responsibilities in a
science blame instead of taking
responsibility paying attention to
science recognizing the word of the role
of governance and all of this to get the
job done for the American people and so
he's engaged in distractions like
immigration distractions like supporting
people in the street they're all
distractions away from the fact the
known fact that he's a total failure
when it comes to testing and former
presidential candidate or O'Rourke
he had this angry response quote who the
blank do you think is working on the
farms and the feedlots in the packing
houses and processing plants at a time
where we are struggling to feed
ourselves who's in the kitchen who's
picking preparing serving the food we
eat and cleaning up afterwards Greg I
wanted to start with you and and just
you know I know you you're always
attentive to how these political things
work and I thought I had about this was
I wonder if the president is baiting his
critics on the left because he makes a
bold statement about shutting down
immigration but then when you look at
the details the details say oh he's just
suspending it even for people who are
applying for permanent green cards for
60 days and there's an exception an
exception for people in so many guest
worker industries so it's not that huge
a change from where we are right now
yeah so it's not too bad
I think you're right though in the sense
that he knows exactly how the left
reacts right if Trump cured cancer the
New York Times headline would read Trump
cures cancer a common illness among
white nationalists so it's it's so he
knew this would happen and it is hard it
is funny when you call something racist
when it benefits
minorities job-wise it's like it it's so
he's cut he's pretty smart and he's kind
of put he's kind of put Biden in a box
on this one because how how was Biden
gonna respond to this remember he called
it racist when we shut it when he shut
down travel so what's he gonna do now
cuz then he had to change his mind so I
think it's um it's at what I it's
exactly what you said it's it's a
moderate response and it's a smart
response you don't allow walk-ons if all
the positions on your team can be
fulfilled by your players so we don't
need walk-ons right now a baseball
address the The Wall Street Journal
I heard you I heard you okay
put me in coach Jesse The Wall Street
Journal call this move by the President
on immigration suspension a political
distraction and they pointed out that
before the coronavirus we had historic
low unemployment well if illegal
immigrants or any kind of immigrant was
taken away jobs how is it that so many
jobs were open just a few weeks ago are
you kidding me 120 million Americans
just lost their jobs in four weeks so
when the economy comes back you want
Americans first in line
I guess these leftists want Americans
second in line behind foreign nationals
it makes no sense to me this is a
no-brainer let's just take Nancy Pelosi
for a second she must have a brain
freeze from all that pricey ice cream
because science has driven every single
decision here science was the one that
shut down travel from China and Europe
shot science was the thing that shut
down the US economy if she thinks Donald
Trump shut down the greatest economy in
the world an economy that was going to
win him reelection
because of politics then Donald Trump
must be the dumbest politician in
America besides beta or Roarke because
here's the situation Nancy who's living
in a quarantine in her mansion
overlooking the San Francisco Bay would
she right now open her door to a
stranger a foreign national who she
doesn't know where they came from if
they've been quarantined if they've been
tested know why Nance because
it tells you you don't do that so why
should America do that now and it's like
I said it's economics one economics 101
and if they want to run on open borders
and foreign labor
be my guest she's gonna lose her gavel
just like she's losing her mind well I
would I was talking about The Wall
Street Journal which is a pretty
conservative editorial page and Dana
here's what the journal said they said
you know the economic evidence points to
immigration helping with recovery
helping with growth and others have
pointed out that it's something like 16%
of our doctors and health care workers
are immigrants but and well and that's
why I think that you know he is big
purposely I guess when he does the
initial tweet but then when you actually
get to the end of it you find out that
it's actually a very I wouldn't even say
it's moderates it's pretty mild did to
have a pause for 60 days and there's
carve-outs for farmworkers and health
care workers they're probably at the end
of this will be engineers etc because it
is true we know that America is fueled
by entrepreneurship and a lot of those
entrepreneurs are immigrants something
are we have that in our own families
history on this show so I think that you
know fool me once when you react so
aggressively to one of the president's
big tweets and then I guess it's you
know it's his communication style then
you wait and you find out that the
policy is really not that different and
so if you're Joe Biden you really are in
a box because if you react to the
initial tweet and you have that you're
going to have to pay for until the
election and then you actually get to
the policy like oh I actually agree with
that yeah it's kind of curious so judge
there's no evidence that immigration is
associated with the spread of the virus
can you agree to that much well I don't
know if we know enough right aren't we a
country that is now relying on studies
and science and I don't think anyone's
capable of answering that but I think
the important point here is that when
the economy does come back a lot of
these businesses you know the 22 million
Americans who are out of work and I'm
sure it's going up again at the end of
the week
you're not gonna have a business to go
back to and as between them and someone
coming in from another country to get
that job whatever that number is however
small people may think that this change
is according to the president's order
here it's significant to American
families and in the end that's the you
know here's the President of the United
States for Americans and the more that
Joe Biden starts talking about
immigration the more he goes down into
the rabbit hole because he's got to
remember he's running to be President of
the United States no other country and
it's gonna bite him in the butt I think
but that's just me